if you went up to someone who didn't
know anything about the internet maybe
someone who just came here through a
time portal from 1920 and you told them
that the focal point of life for most
children in our culture is a little
screen and they spend almost all their
time just staring at this thing and they
care about nothing as much as they care
about the screen that person would
automatically recognize this is a very
bad development no other information is
required in fact he would go back in his
in the time machine to his own time
period in a panic Having learned that
human beings 100 years in the future
have become volunt l zombified no
research required to know that it is bad
but in any event we do have research and
there's a lot of it researchers have
demonstrated a causal link between
social media use and poor mental health
outcomes it's not just correlation it
goes beyond that